nope tongue back
that's me trying cbd at a shop in new
york city
lately i've seen this stuff everywhere
at your local health food store but also
at urban outfitters sephora and cbd
shops like this one and if you look at
some of the branding it kind of makes
sense these products claim to help with
everything from anxiety to insomnia to
muscle pain it almost sounds too good to
be true and maybe it is
to find out i set up a little experiment
for one week i took cbd three times a
day while at the same time i tracked my
anxiety with a scorecard and i also
chatted with an expert before and after
to sort through the results
here's what i learned
[Applause]
cbd is a distant cousin of thc that's
the psychoactive chemical in marijuana
they both come from the cannabis plant
but cbd isn't psychoactive meaning it
doesn't get you high now of course
getting high isn't the only reason why
cannabis is popular people also use it
to relieve pain control seizures and
lessen anxiety but as researchers like
dr yasmin hurd are discovering
it's likely cbd not thc that's behind
these benefits it can
activate some serotonin receptors and
serotonin system is associated with
alleviating anxiety dr hurd has been
studying the effects of cbd for over 10
years and she's found that it can reduce
anxiety in people with a history of
heroin addiction now fortunately i don't
have a history of addiction but i do see
a therapist for chronic anxiety and cbd
could help both under normal conditions
and in people who have anxiety disorders
enough research has started to show that
it does have an anti-anxiety effect so
back at the shop i tried all kinds of
products
from sweets
tastes like chocolate to lotions and
sprays
i think i missed my mouth
and while dr heard couldn't recommend a
specific dose for me she did say that
300 milligrams should be enough to feel
something if i take it every day
because participants in clinical trials
typically take anywhere from 300 to 600
milligrams
so those chocolates and sprays yeah they
weren't gonna cut it instead i went for
something different tinctures
right these these are where you really
get into the higher strength things
i decided to err on the side of caution
and take 250 milligrams each day broken
out into three doses 50 milligrams in
the morning 100 milligrams at midday and
another 100 milligrams at night that way
it wouldn't hit me all at once all right
today is the day
i'm kind of nervous all right here we go
now mind you this was a wednesday a work
day
it's a 50.
so gross i mean my mouth is like filled
with oil right now it's like a nasty
feeling it doesn't taste good
side note the reason i'm taking cbd this
way is that there are tons of
capillaries under your tongue
so anything you put there can be
absorbed directly into your bloodstream
now that's different than when you
ingest cbd like with that chocolate a
lot of it is broken down by your stomach
so you probably won't feel much
anyway several hours later i took my
last dose of the day and i would say
and if anything
i just feel
extremely tired that was the first thing
i noticed that cbd was making me drowsy
really drowsy
dr heard said that's actually a pretty
normal side effect at high doses so
tired but as i discovered the next night
it might also be great for hangovers see
i went to a concert carly rae
anyway i had some alcohol
the next morning
i felt great and according to dr heard
that might be because cbd also has some
anti-inflammatory effects
but what about anxiety what i was really
in this for
each morning i filled out the anxiety
scorecard that dr heard gave me it's a
rough estimate of my daily emotional
state based on numbered responses to
statements like i feel at ease
but day to day it was a lot harder to
figure out whether cbd was actually
helping
after
three days now of cbd i'm
mostly just tired
but over the weekend i finally got that
relief i was looking for even more
quickly than i had expected
so i happened to take cbd right before i
had to do something kind of stressful
today
and
i took 100 milligrams
felt like pretty quickly felt my nerves
calming down and i was like oh my god
this is totally working
um which is really great because i feel
like i'm looking for that like quick
relief as everyone is now of course this
could have been a placebo i mean all of
this could be placebo
so a few days later i tried it again in
a similar high stress situation i'm not
gonna lie i actually feel a little bit
more calm it kind of like puts me into
this almost like disassociative state i
will say that i've also been listening
to the lion king soundtrack so like
maybe that's a part of it when is the
lion king not gonna relax you right at
that point i just had one day left i
must say i am kind of excited to stop
having to take this three times a day i
think part of it is just like scheduling
it and remembering
i've also just been so much more tired i
don't feel like my anxiety was kind of
washed away
i felt like there were a few times where
it really helped in certain instances
and
like overall kind of
maybe lowered the intensity of how i was
feeling because i felt kind of lethargic
at the end i looked over my anxiety
scorecard and sure enough it showed that
i was feeling slightly less anxious on
my last day compared to my first
especially when i looked at statements
like this
yeah that's a big one for me and i was
excited to run these results by dr hurt
how do you feel
um to be honest i don't feel that
different
um i i think that the biggest change
that i noticed is i was just tired all
the time kind of like slo-mo like
lethargia
that makes me feel like a little bit
disassociated with reality but quite
kind of in a good way and i think that
that is like what made me feel a little
less anxious at times taking it at night
only
might be the best
so that this way get past the
initial
sedative effects
or groggy effects and then
you don't have to worry about taking
other things like caffeine or someone to
try and keep away and what about those
moments of more instant relief was that
in my head or could cbd act that fast
yeah absolutely for us in our studies
you know people did
shortly after getting cbd but again at
higher doses then you had did
report reduced anxiety but if there was
one takeaway from our conversations
it was this cbd ironically even though
it's now this huge fat in our society we
still don't have a very good handle on
how it's working in other words we don't
know what size dose you should take how
exactly it changes your brain or how it
impacts different people in different
ways and that's largely because until
late 2018
nearly all cbd was classified as an
illegal substance which made it really
difficult for scientists to study and
while research is starting to catch up
in some ways it's kind of too late it's
one of the first times in history that
the public is determining whether
something is medicine not scientists and
physicians
as for me will i continue using cbd
yeah but likely only for those moments
when i need that instant relief
because while it seems to benefit a lot
of people
i'm personally not fully convinced
and also because this bottle
it costs more than 130 dollars
and if i'm gonna spend that much on
anything i want to be totally sure that
it works
[Music]
you